OK, let's go next to our caller from the six
one four area code, who is finding themselves
on the line today from six one four.
Hi, David.
This is Roshini from Powell, Ohio, who lost
Cheaney, OK.
I realizing when you send Super Chat's I've
been mispronouncing your name, but I appreciate
that now.
It's OK.
Yeah, it's cool that you remember that.
But I just have a I have a question for like
the longer that the long runs of the progressive
parties, I recently saw a clip from the car
Kolinsky show where he talks about how, you
know, he gave his input that if the if the
left and progressives want to enact progressive
policies, they would have to take over the
Democratic Party because we're obviously a
two party system.
And I was just wondering what your what your
view is on that.
Like, do you think that an overrunning of
the other Democratic Party is the way to go
or do you think a third party is an option
so that, you know, the lesser of two evils
argument doesn't really exist anymore?
So I was just wondering what you thought about
that.
Listen, you really have to work both angles
at the same time.
Obviously, in an ideal system, we wouldn't
have a two party system where if you're not
a Democrat or a Republican, at least, that
everything other than a local level, you essentially
have no power.
Even the few independents in the Senate caucus
with the Democrats in this case, it's Bernie
and Angus King.
So I would be working to try to change campaign
finance and how elections are structured,
which are really the two big issues that we
need to change if a third party is ever going
to have a shot.
But simultaneously, if you only do that and
you don't infiltrate the Democratic Party
at all, you could lose five, 10, 20 or 100
years.
I mean, who knows how long that first process
is going to take?
So you need to be doing both.
You've got to be able to walk and chew gum
at the same time.
Right.
Yeah, yeah, absolutely.
I mean, I just I always thought that the answer
was somewhere in the middle and you don't
have to kind of go to one side or the other.
So, yeah, I appreciate that.
Thank you so much.
David, thanks for everything you do.
All right.
Thank you for the call.
Great to hear from you.